也怎样才可以成为一个情绪稳定的人，
现在情绪老不稳定了啊，
就是情绪稳定这个事儿吧，
他是一个综合的结果，
要想拿到这个综合的结果，
他需要的确实是很多方面，
比如说我跟他伙聊过，
说我现在情绪挺稳定的，
好像怎么着都行，
不管出现什么状况，
好像都能接受这么一个状态，
他首先是自己的目前的这个能力得到位，
就是说不管谁抛弃你，
不管谁跟你翻脸，
不管谁跟你矛盾，
你最终你知道一个结果是我肯定能把自己养的很好。
所以如果想修炼成一个情绪稳定的人，
首先是形成一个经济独立的人，
这是一方面啊，
另一方面就是你原生家庭如果说关系特别紧张的话，
就尽量啊少接触，
如果你婆媳关系非常紧张的话，
就尽量离得远一点，
如果说你两口子关系比较紧张，
但又没有什么原则性的问题的话，
想办法去缓和一下，
你不要觉得说我要主动向他去低头了，
是不是我在这段关系里面就属于劣势了，
别这么想，
问题就是给自己营造一个良好的亲密关系，
这件事情是我自己要去攻克的一个课题，
我要去攻克这个课题的时候，
你甭管我采用什么手段，
你甭管我采用什么方法，
我可以芭个娇，
我可以卖个萌，
我可以彼此。
下只要把这个关系掌握在我的手上了，
开关掌握在我的手上了，
我自己的亲密关系经营的好了，
我的情绪稳定有帮助，
我情绪一旦稳定了之后呢，
对待谁都相对于宽容，
那对我的事业，
对我的工作也有帮助，
包括对我的身体都有帮助，
这个大家能接受吗？
方面是一定要先修炼自己的经济独立性，
一方面的话分析一下你的情绪不稳定主要来自于哪里，
反就有的时候想做个复盘，
你的情绪不稳定主要是来自原生家庭啊，
爸爸妈妈还是公公婆婆啊，
还是老公啊，
还是孩子啊，
还是工作呀，
还是单位同事啊，
还是跟你的上级啊，
还是下级啊，
你分析一下你的情绪不稳定，
比如说啊，
你一天发10个脾气，
这10个脾气当中，
百分之多少是谁导致的，
这个很关键，
然后就想针对那个导致你情绪不稳定的人，
这个关系你怎么能够控制他，
怎么能够调整他这么个逻辑。